called the broker up I said Griffin
bye he said buy what I said you know
what to buy buy Zuck he says how do you
spell that I said
z-u-c-k he said that's not the ticker I
said Griffin call Zuck and tell him I
want some shares and so we bought some
shares and I I think we're gonna double
from where we bought
[Music]
it's Friday we're reacting to the news
uh welcome fellas uh let's go through
the stories first of all Facebook stock
is soaring it's up 43 in the last month
uh Sully's getting rich off of it fellas
did you call it did you know that
Facebook was gonna rebound right now
Facebook like I I haven't bought ads on
it recently Sean but I was talking to
some of my folks who worked with you on
the milk row and I was talking to some
of the people who worked at HubSpot who
or the people who worked on the hustle
at HubSpot
Facebook ads are killing it they seem
like they're working really nicely like
when I was running it it was like you
know we're acquiring users for like
three or four dollars and then nowadays
it's back down to like 150 when we first
started so it's kind of easy to see I
guess what about you
uh yeah I I bet on it so I took uh I
don't know 250
000 uh dollars like I don't know three
or four months ago and I bought meta
because I was like why is everybody down
on meta and I was like did they forget
the number one rule you don't bet
against Zuck and um like you know to
anybody who's like oh but the you know
the metaverse blah blah blah I'm like I
just send them the video clip of Mark
Zuckerberg doing MMA
and I'm like
this is who you're trying to bet against
the guy that since age 18 has just been
like dominating everything he's tried to
do the guy who's created the biggest
social network ever then bought all of
his competitors and killed you know
every everybody else who tried to
compete with him including Google uh
when they try to compete with him on
social and now he trains MMA and before
that he learned to hunt and speak
Chinese fluently you think this guy's
just gonna lose money because Apple
changed their cookie policy or whatever
get out of here with that no way and so
uh
called the broker up I said Griffin
bye he said buy what I said you know
what to buy buy Zuck he says how do you
spell that I said
z-u-c-k he said that's not the ticker I
said Griffin calls up and tell him I
want some shares and so we bought some
shares and I I think we're gonna double
from where we bought it I don't know
where I don't know exactly I think it's
80 I'm up 80 on that that Sean Sean and
I used the same guy by the way we both
use Griffin what did Griffin say Let me
let me actually check the number so I
don't I don't misquilt myself here did
he did he say are you sure Sean or is he
goes yes sir go go and do it well he
texted me the other day he goes great
call on meta and I go
thank you for the compliment because
I've lost a lot of money this year and
yeah that's why I sent this
okay not quite double but uh but close
um we will be double so we're up Fifth
only only 50 so it's a little bit a
little bit less than I thought 50 still
still not bad in a couple months
dude Sarah started working at Sarah used
to work at Facebook in 2012 and I was
like doing some math about what she
would have yeah 2012 she started or
sorry 14 she started working there and I
was doing the math on like where she
would be if she just stayed there and we
were talking about it and it was like
well Pro you would have gotten fairly
wealthy Khan like her job there was like
how do I make like a sticker emoji that
gets people in Brazil to share more
selfies so it's like you know you want
to like you're going to want to like
kill yourself and this is black and lame
but like they pay for your lunch and you
get that you get our oil changed and
like that stock back then was only 47 at
its peak was 372 dollars I mean that's
pretty sick but yeah man like Facebook's
killer never bet against them dude when
we were uh going through our sale
process Facebook was one of the
potential buyers
uh no no this was 2019 2020 something
like that 19. okay so back then it was a
200 yeah so we so it's it's good that
the stock is down from when we would
have got acquired because it was you
know stock was a significant part of the
deal but um we were the the difference
of talent quality between we interviewed
with uh we talked to YouTube we talked
to said twitch where we ended up going
to Facebook to Discord to a bunch of
other players and Facebook was so much
more so much better so much more
impressive I was like um okay you know
like if I was just going off of
who what talent would we be around it's
not even close like the numbers are not
even CL like the math of the difference
of these offers is not even close but I
was yeah optimizing a lot of the things
a lot of people who have who I've talked
with whoever hit Facebook they're sharp
as hell like
um I remember just walking around that
campus it felt like I was at the UN you
know what I mean like there's like like
there's so many different like types of
like colors and like ethnicities it was
like they just like Cherry Picked the
best of all over the world and it was at
that was it Menlo Park or I forget where
it was but like walking around that
campus I feel inspired one of the guys
who would have been reporting to me
there he was like yeah as my um like
intro like when you get there you do
like a demo project or you do like an
intro project I guess if you're early on
as a engineer or product manager or
something like that
um to like just get onboarded you do
like a hackathon project and he created
basically Facebook Marketplace in that
and they ended up running that like
working on that but it was like you know
his prototype was like one of the
original Genesis things and another guy
was like uh I was like what'd you do
before this he's like oh I was at
Microsoft I was like okay one boring
thing to another great and he's like so
yeah I invented uh the the you know
Microsoft 365 like uh you know I was
like we should go to the cloud and make
this a subscription and nobody agreed
with me and I just kept working on it
for like two years and um he's like I
just literally had a separate machine
under my desk where I was like I'm gonna
build it on this machine and like I'm
gonna do it here and I was like
okay so my takeaway was like you guys
are smart man if I come here I'm gonna
have to work uh I'm gonna have to work
hard you know because you can't just
like be lazy around these people they're
great
um all right which one uh which one do
we go to now let's go Jack butcher uh
Jack butcher's nft project which is uh
called checks V4 it's a bunch of art
around uh the check mark has recently
become the top trading nft project by
volume uh surpassing board Apes I didn't
realize it was that big
I think that's probably like on a this
week type basis yeah that's correct yeah
yeah not all time in terms of like
active trading volume uh either this
week or uh in a single Bay
um but uh what do you guys have to say
to our boy buddy Jack's getting rich
love it dude so I'm biased Jack's like a
close family friend him and his wife
um are very I'm very close with those
folks they are awesome and Jack is more
of an artist close enough that he sent
you some of these nfts oof well I got a
t-shirt that says internet on it that I
he sent me a 30 coupon code
um I got a t-shirt Jack uh dude Jack's
punk rock man Jack's more of an artist
than he is a businessman and um if you
go to his website
um visualize value and you read the copy
for the check mark it is
as we like to say beautifully done
it's it's like it's it's just an nft but
it's just so tasteful it's classy uh
it's delightful no he's done a good job
man I I think it's cool I still I'm not
I'm not an nft guy you know cornrows
neck tattoos nfts not for me uh but cool
that other people have them and that's
kind of how I feel about an nft still
but if I were gonna do an nft it'd be
his
yeah it looks like the last seven days
it's done 15 million in sales volume no
[__]
and uh it's the fourth ranked one in the
last seven days maybe so so really
impressive uh right I
don't say it like that okay is Nike just
a swoosh look I'm not saying it that way
uh what is it I didn't actually is it
like uh you get a different color check
and you put that Azure no I'm not
disrespecting it at all but I'm
wondering I'm asking uh because I'm not
I'm not in this world it went from eight
dollars which was the price that Elon
was trying to charge for a blue check on
Twitter right so that's like the state
the political statement he's making here
so it went from eight dollars which was
his like opening price I think to closer
to four thousand dollars per per nft now
so incredible incredible surge
um and he is like
I don't know he's not there yet this is
sort of like comparing a little bit of a
stretch of a comparison but
he's kind of like a um internet Banksy a
little bit like he does total [__]
that's like it's a commentary on what's
going on in the world and he just the
guy just hits he just hits like I have I
seen him do anything like that it's all
that's dope H.O hits only and he's a few
people who has ho status
dude he makes hits he uh so he started
out Jacks are good buddy If You Don't
Know Jack follow him on Twitter he
started out uh he had an ad agency and
then he uh he worked at an ad agency and
then he started to make his own Ad
Agency and it was going okay and then he
created this course called build once
sell twice which is hilarious amazing
name yeah amazing name and it's about
how to
product ties a service and he starts
selling that course and he basically was
like I remember I did a call with him
and his wife one time when we first
started getting to know one another and
they were in like a 400 or 500 square
foot studio apartment that they lived in
and they weren't like killing it and
then like he had the year of his life in
2020 or 2021 kills it now if you go to
his website virtualizedvalue.com the
reason why I love him is you see like
his background you see his courses but
he also has this tab called visuals
where you can like look at some of his
artwork but then he has a merch store
and his merch store is actually awesome
he has these sweatshirts that say
college kind of like you know that but
it says internet and like he just does
things like that that are actually
awesome and it like when I go to his
site I'm like oh I'm like this dorky
internet guy too but he has merch I'm
inspired to be uh like a lot cooler like
he is it's awesome he's he's badass I'm
a Big Jack fan me too me too we're we're
big fans of him all right what's up all
right next up we got uh moonwalkers uh
it's a new shoe that's like half a
roller skate I don't know if you guys
had a chance to open haven't looked at
it yet but it allows you to walk and you
just walk but you go seven miles an hour
which is roughly three times as fast as
a normal person walks
it's uh it's on um
Kickstarter it's raised three hundred
thousand dollars uh the shoes cost more
than a thousand dollars
are you guys there God you gotta see the
video These are so stupid and so awesome
they're basically just
Heelys for dorks who work at a startup
uh like the Heelys for people with no
balance yeah this is
which this is crazy this video is
hilarious uh it's really dumb but kind
of awesome if we did an award for a
person most likely to have started this
that I know
Sam I think you would have been the guy
me dude this is like the Snuggie of
shoes tell me how you feel about boosted
boards
well boosted boards are dope right it's
the same thing
one for each foot dude oh my God this is
this is like
this is like driving a Kia man you're
never gonna get late again if you ever
like get caught in one of these hey I
like his
um bro you have a BMW for a reason
I saw this on um Tick Tock and it had
millions of likes I think it had like
two or three million likes on this video
and I was like I could see why it is uh
gonna be controversial it is like
visually stunning you can't tell if it's
a joke or if it's serious uh like this
literally looks like The Tick Tock and
the ad for it literally looks like
something from Silicon Valley the HBO
show
um like the guy the founder he's like
this guy's you know Shinji and he's like
this Asian guy who's talking about like
you know as humans we've we've always
been stuck at two miles an hour and
finally we've broken the barrier we go
seven now he's sitting in front of like
these three screens like these huge
MacBook screens of my all right I'm
experience like dude what are you
programming like it's a shoe with it's
roller skates
roller skates it's gonna revolutionize
the way that people get hit by cars
that's what this is gonna do uh it just
we're changing the world you go if you
look at it
the kickstarter backers our only
personal injury lawyers who are like oh
yeah no brainer business expense type
this one off dude this is just Segway
2.0 it's really stupid but also kind of
cool
um yeah I just uh I mean this is like uh
this is like guys who wear like their
cell phones outside of their pocket or
who wear a Jawbone 24 7. um it's this is
that Niche uh not for me
I'll give it to Andrew Tate
I'm out yeah I'm out
it's wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a task
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
let's do one more what's the you want to
do the Tooth Fairy thing
yeah okay I got a new story for you uh
my sister has three daughters um two of
which are losing their baby teeth and um
I was talking to my niece the other day
and she tells me that uh she lost a
tooth I said wow fantastic you're gonna
give it to you put on your pillow for
the Tooth Fairy no I threw it away he
threw it away he threw it to the garbage
can yeah I threw it away why well my
last tooth was under there for two
months and the Tooth Fairy never came so
um so I don't I don't wanna I don't want
to even try anymore uh that's the first
first story I hear and I'm looking at my
sister she's like making eye contact
like I'll tell you later I'm sorry I
know I know I act up
then the younger daughter loses her
tooth yesterday
puts it under uh her pillow with a note
here's what the note says it's I'll I'll
send you a picture of it but basically
it says something to the effect of uh
um dear Tooth Fairy
um you didn't come last night but that's
okay I uh I'm leaving it here again and
it says something like you don't have to
leave any money just draw a picture of
yourself I want to see what you look
like and then that's the note and she
didn't do anything again so the news the
the question fellas does my sister need
to just check herself into jail for bad
mom of the year what the hell What's
your deal what's what
just give like a few dollars or like
she forgot
how do you forget that uh unbelievable
she texted me she said that herself she
goes should I just send myself to Jail
uh because I'm such a bad mom
that's crazy to me that's my new story
of the week that that's what I pay
attention to
what's a tooth go for nowadays five
dollars I don't know dude back in my day
that was you know like five or like if
your parents get cheeky they're like
here's a two dollar bill and it's less
than the going rate but it's rare it's a
two dollar bill you know like I got a
five dollar once uh and that was like a
huge deal I don't know what's a tooth go
for I feel like people do more than Ben
what were you did you get tooth money
when you were growing up I got a quarter
I don't feel like I grew up a [__] but
now I feel like I grew up poor yeah I
would get like a quarter or a dollar but
then one time I got a tooth knocked out
and I got five bucks for it that's some
guilt money right there that it was
yellow money yeah blood money I fell and
got it knocked out so I got five bucks
for that one but I don't know what a
tooth would go for now
um but do this uh do this other one you
have the Snowden one I don't know if
you've seen this one yeah so Edward
Snowden goes live on a conference and uh
the conference is um I don't know it
just screams like uh
fake Zoom conference right the the let's
see what it's called it's called Uh
private investor conference or something
like that the most generic name of all
time yes and so uh this guy is
interviewing Edward Snowden for his
private investor conference he shows up
and immediately pulls up an article that
says uh man busted for 4.4 million
dollar Ponzi scheme and he says is this
you and the host the interviewer says
yeah that's me he goes all right well I
think it's important to tell people this
kind of stuff buy and hangs up on him he
got paid to come do a keynote
he starts his like you know keynote q a
or whatever and just pulls screen shares
instead the the news article that this
guy who's hosting this event
is a former like you know Ponzi schemer
that was like you know I got trouble for
that and the chat is just like wow wow
boom wow oh my god wow it's the best
like uh you know I don't want to go to
many webinars but I wish I was at this
one shout out to Edward Snowden you know
whistleblower is gonna blow dude
have you ever seen the subreddit it's on
the subreddit called watch people die
uh yeah I've seen that one yeah this is
gonna be on the top sorry I I screwed
that up watch people die inside yeah
inside whoops yeah the inside's a big
thing uh next uh there's a somebody
called absolute units have you seen that
one
I love that one this is like a buff dog
or like a pimple that's huge it's called
like a cucumber that's like just too
strong to be cut yeah I love absolute
units but I subscribe to Absolute units
and I subscribe to watch people die in
the uh watch people die inside this is
one of them uh this video is on there uh
well do you see the rates watching the
guy's reaction so the guy goes yeah yes
that's me and then snowden's like well I
think people should know you know who
they're getting into business with
whatever so I don't feel good about this
I'm I'm not doing this so he leaves and
then the guys doesn't know what to do
and he just shrinks and he just goes
um okay I'm gonna we're gonna take a
break and um
yeah I'm gonna come back and he just
doesn't know what to say it's like man
if there was ever a time to be like hey
uh you know I know that looked bad but
um I'm happy to explain and uh you know
explain what happened and and you know
clarify for everybody you know I can do
that right here right now no problem
dude and there's people like he shrinks
there's people in the chat saying like
hey Edward are flying saucers real like
and people on Reddit are like yeah no
wonder why these people fall for this uh
this guy private investor Club yeah oh
my gosh this is crazy yeah this is a
good video I'm gonna have to watch this
um dude I've been following some of
these like Ponzi scheme guys on um like
they do all these like um
for example there was one what's that
there's a twitch guy with dreadlocks
he's a black dude not uh the famous one
who boxes but like another one who's
like more hated and uh he's like loud
and cocky I forget his name but uh very
punchable guy
um but he was like uh uh uh a crypto
company like paid him to do like an ad
and they're in the background talking
about and he forgets that he's recording
and he's like dude I can't believe
people are gonna buy this crap or
something like that you know what I'm
talking about what's that guy's name I'm
a very hatable guy I don't know I don't
know who that guy is but I've seen the
clip but yeah like the the owner or the
promoter of the thing was behind him and
they're they're talking I don't know
what exactly what he said I don't think
he said that he said something else but
it was something
I picked it up and people were like wow
dude disgusting
the the amount of like the the twitch
and I think I said twilio I meant twitch
the twitch and like YouTube audience
that buys this crap it is crazy man it
is absolutely crazy to me
um I can't believe people do that but
yeah this was a good one how did this
guy afford Edward Snowden
dude you know how Ponzi schemers work
they know how to build it you know they
got to build this uh this shell game
this appearance of uh of legitimacy
that's crazy to me uh it's the it's the
private investment Club it's the largest
uh largest Real Estate club in Canada
that's like his shtick uh that's crazy
to me um anyway yeah that's a good video
I'm gonna have to watch that all right
that's it we're out of here boys react
[Music]